Lauren Holly's NCIS character Jennifer
Shepard spent her whole career working
her way up to becoming director of the
Naval Criminal Investigative Service
only to be gunned down some three years
into the top job the last fan saw of
Shepard was in an abandoned diner
getting sentimental with fellow NCIS
agent Mike Franks her death happens off
screen signified by a storm of gunshots
and a mostly obscured shot of her body
but we know she didn't go quietly
replacement director Leon Vance said
that the forensics from the scene
indicated that Shepard went down
fighting she put up a hell of a fight
Paulie on the other hand wasn't fighting
against her character's death and
departure from the show she joined NCIS
at the start of season three with her
character replacing former NCIS director
Thomas Morrow
and appeared on a total of 48 episodes
up to the season 5 finale sometimes
learning the real reason NCIS actors
left raises more questions about the
show's famous backstage drama but unlike
some of her former co-stars it seems
like Holly left on her own terms three
seasons on a show that's into its second
decade doesn't seem like a long time in
the grand scheme of things but Holly
never expected to last even that long on
NCIS in a now-deleted post on her
personal website she wrote that she
initially found her way to NCIS through
her former Chicago Hope co-star Mark
Harmon who of course is best known today
as fearless NCIS leader Agent leroy
jethro gibbs excited at the chance to
again work with harmon and with
legendary creator Don Belisario Holly
originally went up for the part that
went to Sasha Alexander but two years
later Holly was invited to join the show
with the understanding that she would be
part of a six episode story arc as the
new director of NCIS Holly was living in
Chicago at the time and she started
commuting back and forth to LA for the
show when the creators offered to extend
the part into future seasons Holly and
her family moved to California not every
departure from the show has been smooth
sailing
Holly however apparently didn't have any
hard feelings she wrote I enjoyed being
on the show and began some wonderful
friendships
but two years in Hawley was happy to bow
out of the series saying that after
playing the same character day in and
day out for such a long time she was
bored and wanted a new challenge
ultimately she was happy with how
shepard met her demise
according to holly after she left the
showrunners know that she wanted out the
decision was made to kill me and boy did
they about five different ways
Holly's only exaggerating a little bit
Shepard had been diagnosed with a fatal
brain tumor before she was ultimately
taken out by a group of assassins
NCIS continued on without Shepard and
the actress hopes the series extends its
long run even further for the sake of
the cast and crew she wrote a lot of
people depend on it for their families
for that I hope it continues forever it
probably will I think of them all often
while some actors face the unfortunate
fate of a quickly dimming career after
leaving a hit series that couldn't be
further from the truth for Holly she's
continued to flourish in both the
television and film realms post NCIS
which should come as no surprise
considering how many screen credits
she'd racked up prior to joining the
show since exiting NCIS Holly has
appeared on series such as leverage
Lucifer and Good Witch she's also lent
her voice to the computer animated
television show The Adventures of Chuck
and Friends playing the aptly named
Holly an anthropomorphic forklift
Holly's biggest television gig after
NCIS came in 2013 when she began
starring in the Canadian police
procedural series motive a gig that
lasted until August 2016
most recently Holly has held a recurring
role as Lynne Harper on the political
drama designated survivor
he's a wonderful partner he's attentive
and irreproachable and unimpeachably
correct she doesn't mean that as a
compliment on the film side of things
fans likely best remember seeing Holly
as Linda in 2015's the Black Codes
daughter written and directed by Osgood
Perkins the film centers around two
students who are left behind at their
boarding school during winter break it's
rumored that the school's nuns worship
Satan talk that turns out to be a lot
less terrifying than the truth of the
situation
NCIS was in arguably a bright spot in
Holly's professional career even if she
did get bored of the gig after a while
but it's clear that her future is even
brighter check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]